WAI CHEE DIMOCK: In Our Time,
as we'll find out,
many of the titles of the
novels are actually from very
canonical works, or very
ancient works in the
case of Faulkner.
In the case of Hemingway, the
title is from the Book of
Common Prayer.
"Give us peace in our time, O
Lord." So it's very much a
meditation on war and peace
and thinking about what
happens in war and also thinking
about what happens
when we have theoretical peace,
but maybe war is still
going on in some fashion.
So it's really praying
for peace.
I should talk a little bit about
the publication history
of In Our Time.
It has a very interesting and
complicated publication history.
Initially, a lot of the
vignettes from In Our Time--
what we would call vignettes,
Hemingway call chapters--
those were published first. So
they were published in the
little reviews.
And this one is actually called
The Little Review.
And so there's some
publishing there.
And some of the stories,
actually, were also published
in the little reviews.
And this one is called what we
now call "Indian Camp" that
we'll be talking about today,
that was published in The
Transatlantic Review.
And the first edition of In
Our Time was actually
published in Paris.
It was published by the Three
Mountains Press, looking
handcrafted--
in fact, it was handcrafted.
Only 30 pages, so really just
all the vignettes, all the
chapters were in that edition.
And only 170 copies
were printed.
So this is really the
very beginning
of Hemingway's career.
And it's really interesting to
see that that's how he started
out, someone who really
was thinking of 170
people reading his work.
But even though only 170
copies were printed, it
actually got very, very warm
responses right away.
And it is actually amazing to
think that it got picked up
right away by Fitzgerald, who
wrote his editor, Maxwell
Perkins at Scribner's, saying
that the vignettes are really
remarkable, I'll look
him up right away.
He's the real thing.
So this is back in 1924 when
Hemingway was a total unknown.
So the first American
edition was
published by Boni & Liveright.
This is Hemingway's
first publisher.
He would then move on to
Scribner's, and Scribner's is
the publisher that controls all
the copyright to all the
Hemingway novels.
But he started out with
Boni & Liveright.
And there were a few more--
not just the vignettes, now--
but a few of the stories were
included in this 1925 edition
of In Our Time, but still
a very handmade look.
And Hemingway did not have a
very happy relation to Boni &
Liveright, mostly having
to do with the
structure of In Our Time.
On April 22, he wrote to his
good friend, author John Dos
Passos, saying, "A Mrs. George
Kaufman is here and she claims
they want to cut it all out--
the Indian Camp story.
Cut the In Our Time chapters.
Jesus I feel all shot
to Hell about it.
Of course they can't do it
because the stuff is so tight
and hard and everything hangs
on everything else." This is
1925, but already we can see
the Hemingway that we
recognize later, somebody who
loves his material, wants his
material to be tight and hard
and everything hanging on
everything else.
But still, it is a very, very
strange claim, given the fact
that in fact, the publication
history of In Our Time
suggests that it wasn't
conceived of and it wasn't
initially published as
all in one piece.
It was actually published
separately.
But meanwhile Hemingway is going
to claim that in fact,
he wants everything
all in one piece.
So I think that this is
something that we should
really think about.
We should certainly take
Hemingway very seriously that
he's insisting that everything
is hanging together.
But also maybe entertaining the
possibility that maybe a
bit looser than he would like
to think or that he claims.
So let's think about rather
than taking Hemingway
completely at his word, let's
just say that we'll think of
the narrative structure
of In Our Time
as a puzzling structure.
And this is something
that we can say.
There's not much dispute
about it.
It doesn't look like a short
story collection.
It doesn't look like anything
else that we've read.
So this very unusual structure
of the stories being
interspersed with
the chapters.
And there seems to be an
apparent disjunction
between these two.
And there's also a kind of very
rapid shift of location
and perspective between those
pieces that are set in wartime
Europe and those that are set
in peacetime America in the
Midwest. So it doesn't
work as a linear,
streamline kind of narrative.
It doesn't look like a
traditional novel.
collection of short stories.
So there's something to think
about, to puzzle over.
So what I'd like to do today is
actually to give Hemingway
the benefit of the doubt.
He's saying that everything
hangs together.
So let's read three pieces
as if they did
in fact hang together.
So this is an experiment
in reading.
We can never prove for
sure that they do
in fact hang together.
But because Hemingway is so
emphatic about it, let's just
do this little experiment
of reading three--
two stories and then
one inter-chapter--
as if they all belong
together as a unit.
But to say that is also to say
that you guys can experiment
with other clusters.
This is a possible cluster.
You can experiment with other
possible clusters.
So when it comes to writing
papers, this is a great
opportunity to try out to see
which goes with what.
So the three that I'm proposing
to read together is
first of all "Indian Camp." We
know for a fact that that was
published separately.
So let's not forget
that for a moment.
But still given that it was
initially published in The
Transatlantic Review, let's
group it with the other two.
And then "Chapter II" and then
"The Doctor and the Doctor's
Wife." The reason that those
three hang together in my mind
is that they work on the
same thematic register.
And they also work on the same
macro, micro-registers that we
were talking about last time.
So the macro-register is that
there is the tension between
the Anglos and the
Native Americans.
Both these stories--
let's leave out the chapter
first, because it's obviously
about something else.
But "Indian Camp" and "The
Doctor and the Doctor's Wife,"
they both are about the
relations between the Anglos
and the Native Americans and
about tension and conflict
between them.
And both stories also share some
important similarity on
the micro-register.
"Indian Camp" obviously is about
the phenomenon of pain
and about violence to oneself,
about injury, about injury to
others, about violence
to oneself.
And "The Doctor and the Doctor's
Wife" is about
potential violence.
A fight could break out in that
story, but it doesn't.
So in some sense, it's the
opposite of Indian Camp.
It is about the possibility
of violence
that is being averted.
So just on that basis, it would
seem that there's some
kind of relation between them.
So let's look at the
macro-register first. It's not
as macro as the history of World
War I, but it's macro in
the sense that it really is
about important sociological
facts about the United States.
The stories are set
in Horton Bay.
Actually, this is where the
Hemingway family would go for
their summer vacations.
It's in Michigan.
And the Native Americans
are Ojibway--
Anishinaabe is actually the
preferred destination by them,
but mostly Ojibway, I think,
is the more common name--
a very well known group,
very important
group of Native Americans.
So there's a whole book
written about them.
And so this is the background
to the macro-history of the
two stories.
And I'd like to introduce three
additional perspectives
now, on the micro-level which
is talking about the
phenomenon of pain and injury
and violence and so on.
And you might or might not have
read these people, but
they are very influential
people, including obviously a
great painter writing about
pain and injury and so on.
Elaine Scarry, Susan Sontag,
and Edvard Munch.
So let's just begin with
Elaine Scarry.
This is a book that came
out in the 1980s.
It's called A Body in Pain.
And a lot of it actually has
to do-- and she's done
extensive research using
the archives at Amnesty
International--
with looking at the phenomenon
of pain as a
consequence of torture.
And the argument about the book
is that when prisoners
are tortured, when there's
really nothing in the world
open to them except for the
experience of pain, then they
lose the ability to express
themselves.
They lose the ability to have
any kind of linguistic
relation to the world, including
the linguistic
relation of being able to
describe your own pain.
So what she argues is that
there's a breakdown of
language under extreme
conditions of pain.
The pain basically breaks
down our world.
And the first thing, the
most important thing
to go is our language.
Because according to Elaine
Scarry, it is language that
anchors and constitutes
our world.
So it is an argument about the
power of pain and its ability
to dehumanize us, because it
takes away our ability to do
the most fundamentally
human thing, namely
to speak, use language.
So this is one end of
the spectrum in
thinking about pain.
On the other end of the
spectrum, a very, very
different kind of philosophy,
is the public intellectual
Susan Sontag.
She died a few years ago.
But her work has been really,
really important
for decades, really.
And one of her best-known books
is called Regarding the
Pain of Others.
She really has a completely
different take on pain from
Elaine Scarry.
She argues that rather than
thinking about the phenomenon
of pain itself as a kind of
experiential reality for us,
she's interested in how the
observation of pain in others
gives us pleasure, that in some
sense we are affirmed, we
affirm our own being.
We affirm ourselves.
We affirm the fact that we are
not feeling pain when we see
pain in others.
It's a very tough and in many
ways a kind of disturbing
argument, that her basic sense
of the world is that we affirm
our own being by being
able to tell
ourselves apart from others.
So when we see someone in acute
pain, we know that we
are someone else, that we are
what we are, because we're not
going through that pain.
So there's a kind of indirect
pleasure from seeing the pain
in others, and you can see it
in the cover of her book.
So it's a very disturbing
outlook, but
something to keep in mind.
And both of those models
I want to call to your
attention, because I think that
Hemingway actually has
something to say to each
of them, actually.
And I would encourage you in
section to think about what
Hemingway would say to Elaine
Scarry, what Hemingway would
say to Susan Sontag.
He obviously wasn't writing for
them, but given the fact
that he has written stories that
have to do with pain, how
he would respond to
those theories.
But I think that Hemingway is
actually closer to the pain of
Munch, and the very celebrated
painting "The Scream." And
it's really about pain
as a sound, so pain
coming out as a scream.
And it is a corrective to Elaine
Scarry in the sense
that even though we might not be
able to speak when we're in
acute pain, we still are able to
express ourselves, because
we can just cry out, even though
it's not a linguistic,
it's not a word that
we're saying.
The very fact that something is
coming out of us suggests
that the capacity for expression
hasn't completely
broken down.
Munch is not especially
interested in thinking about
what the scream would
do to others.
So basically, this is just
somebody who is crying out in
pain, and probably not bodily
injury either, but just
psychic pain, just
screaming out.
Munch is not putting into the
picture what the scream would
do to other people listening
to that scream.
So I would like to see Hemingway
as collaborating
with Munch.
Munch is giving us the scream
coming out of the person who
is suffering, and "Indian Camp"
is Hemingway's extended
meditation on the phenomenon
of the scream on what the
scream would do to people who
are completely vulnerable to
that sound of pain.
Usually we just think of
ourselves as being
vulnerable to pain.
But we're also vulnerable
to the sound of pain.
So this is a very different
model from the one suggested
by Susan Sontag.
I'm already giving you a bit of
an argument about Hemingway
with saying Sontag is really
thinking about pain as a kind
of a visual pleasure
to other people.
We see other people
suffering and we
get some visual pleasure.
Hemingway is about the auditory
pain that we get as a
consequence of our ears
being helplessly open
to the pain of others.
So there's basically a very
important difference between
the eye and the ear.
And I think most people
would agree that we
can shut our eyes.
We don't have to see something
if we don't want to.
We can't really shut our ears.
We can remove ourselves to a
greater distance and shut our
ears that way, but if we're in
the neighborhood of someone
who is screaming, we can't
really shut our ears.
So "Indian Camp" is really
about what happens when
someone cannot shut his or
her ears to a scream.
So it's about a woman
giving birth.
And Nick's father, who is a
doctor, coming to attend to
that woman.
It's about an Anglo doctor
coming to a very close-knit
Native American community to
take care of a Native American
woman under very primitive
conditions.
But Hemingway spends a lot of
time actually not just talking
about Anglo and Indian
relations, but also about the
relations among Native
Americans.
So this is how the man
reacts to the woman
giving birth and screaming.
"The men had moved off up the
road to sit in the dark and
smoke out of range of
the noise she made.
She screamed just as Nick and
the two Indians follow his
father into the shanty."
So this is actually the baseline
for Hemingway, is
that the scream is unbearable,
even to her own community.
This is someone who is actually
inflicting pain and
injury on her own Native
American community, not
because of any conflict
with them.
So this is a very important
fact to know.
This is not a sociopolitical
conflict,
socioeconomic conflict.
It is not the conflict between
two different ethnic groups.
It is an involuntary
conflict within one
close-knit ethnic group.
The woman can't help
screaming.
She can't help causing pain
to her own community.
So the men are trying to do
the best they can to get
themselves out of the way of
the painful screaming that
they're hearing.
And we can think about what
follows from this given, from
this baseline.
And actually, there
are two outcomes.
And one outcome is actually very
much predicated on the
importance of ethnic
difference.
So here are the Native American
men being completely
overwhelmed and helpless in
the face of the scream.
But one person, one
person who's not
affected by the scream.
Why is he not affected? "But her
screams are not important.
I don't hear them because
they're not important." Who is
it that says that?
The doctor--
exactly, thank you--
is Nick's father.
So what enables him, what
is it that insulates
him from the scream?
It seems that if there is
something else they can
override that sound, there's
something else that is more
important to you than the
immediacy of that sound, it
can serve as a protective
shell.
And as it turns out,
it is the doctor's
professional identity.
Because he's able to explain to
Nick what she's just going
through is something
called labor.
The baby wants to be born.
The baby is trying to be born,
she is trying her best so that
the baby would be born.
He has a completely coherent
explanation as to why she's
going through the pain.
And he has a completely coherent
explanation as to why
she's screaming right now.
So the coherence of that
explanation, and the fact that
he is professionally equipped
to put an end to the scream,
the fact that he as a doctor can
just perform the Caesarian
operation so that the
scream will stop.
Both his ability to explain a
phenomenon and his ability to
put an end to the phenomenon,
those two work together so
that the scream, while a fact
of life, is not going to be
devastating to the doctor.
And we all know that.
If doctors were going to be
devastated by screams, they
wouldn't be doctors, they
wouldn't be able to operate.
So a very important feature of
the professional identity of a
doctor is that they should be
able to take a lot of sensory
input that would be unbearable
to other people and be able to
put that sensory input
in its place.
Being able to explain it is
being able to put it away and
being able to cope with it.
And here's a doctor being
able to cope with that.
So this is one possible
outcome, is that it's
basically a kind of
neutralization of the scream.
It is not piercing, it
is not devastating.
But the process of
neutralization doesn't always
take place.
So this is outcome two.
The doctor, Nick's father, is
congratulating himself that
he's performed an operation,
he's able to do the Caesarian
with just a jackknife.
He's going to write it up for
the medical journals.
He's very, very happy
as a doctor.
He feels very much affirmed.
And then this one other
development.
He looks at the proud father,
the person who ought to be the
proud father.
He quickly turns away and
tells Nick not to look.
So we know what the
outcome two is--
what happens when someone who
is not insulated by his
professional identity
is helplessly
subject to the scream.
"His throat had been cut
from ear to ear.
The blood had flowed down into
a pool where his body sagged
the bunk."
So this is a very extreme
reaction.
I honestly don't know how common
this is, that a father
would just go to the extreme of
taking his own life because
he can't really take the
pain of his wife.
But it's the opposite model from
the Susan Sontag model.
It's not taking pleasure from
the pain of others but being
completely devastated, being
completely destroyed by the
pain of others to such an extent
that you want to take
your biological life because
your inner psychic life has
been so devastated by
what you cannot bear
to go through anymore.
So this is an extreme case of
empathy, a husband empathizing
with the wife, feeling the pain
of his wife to such an
extent, it's almost as if the
pain is doing more to him than
it is actually doing
to his wife.
So this is one way to think
about pain, how natural it is.
It's naturalized because
it has no socioeconomic
explanation to it.
It's just a fact of life that
women will give birth.
And it is a fact of life that
they suffer tremendously when
they give birth.
And it's also a fact of life
that when they suffer, other
people are likely to
suffer as well.
There is kind of a transitive
relation of pain, spreading
out and becoming more and more
common, becoming more and more
a universal condition of life,
because there basically is no
boundary between the pain of
one person and what someone
else is likely to go through.
So we can say that what we see
in "Indian Camp" is to some
extent a story that gestures
in two directions.
On the one hand, there's a lot
of interest in the tension
between Native Americans
and Anglo-Americans.
That's not unimportant.
It pulls in one direction.
It also pulls in another
direction, and it pulls in the
other direction of the
micro-register in terms of
pain, that really the most
fundamental drama is almost
regardless of the
relation between
Anglos and Native Americans.
You do it to everyone, and you
do it every time you go
through pain.
Every time you go into labor,
this is going to happen.
So it's kind of a naturalization
of pain as a
kind of universal condition.
Let's look at the inter-chapter
and test this
possibility whether or not
Hemingway is really wanting to
explore the phenomenon that
there's nothing to be done
about pain, that it is the most
fundamental fact of life,
that it is as natural as
the sense of hearing.
I think that in "Indian Camp"
there's a sense that just as
we can't help the fact that we
have a pair of ears, we can
help the fact that we're going
to be vulnerable to the sounds
of pain made by others.
In "Chapter II," Hemingway is
testing this possibility by
this same kind of play between
the macro and the
micro-register.
So the macro-register is the
Greco-Turkish war which we
already looked at last time.
And this is about the evacuation
of the Greek
civilians when the Turkish
army was just
advancing on them.
So it's the largest possible
context, large-scale
geopolitical warfare.
That's the macro context.
But it's interesting that in
this one very short paragraph,
Hemingway has transitioned
to something else.
So let's just read
this paragraph.
"Greek cavalry herded along
the procession.
The women and kids were in
the carts, crouched with
mattresses, mirrors, sewing
machines, bundles.
There was a woman having a kid
with a young girl holding a
blanket over her and crying.
Scared sick looking at it.
It rained all through
the evacuation."
So obviously this is
classic Hemingway.
About as much is packed into
this one short paragraph as
could be packed into any
short paragraph.
Beginning with the macro context
of the evacuation of
Greek civilians, we move on to
something that clearly is
picking up on the thematic
residue from the first story,
from "Indian Camp," a
woman having a baby.
And it follows the same
structure as well.
Not just a woman having a baby,
but someone watching
that, observing that, and
being terrified of
that fact of life.
So even though we do know that
"Indian Camp" was published
separately, I think that we have
to grant Hemingway the
truth of his statement that
the stories and the
inter-chapters are
really connected.
They're connected
after the fact.
The inter-chapters, at least
this particular one, is
obviously written as a
continuation of a meditation
on the pain of childbirth.
And not just the pain of
childbirth as experienced by
the person who's going through
that phenomenon, going through
the experience, but also as an
observational pain in someone
who is just an onlooker, what
it does to the onlooker.
It's the same kind of dynamics
of being terrified, being
scared sick looking at it.
So it's not quite as extreme
as the husband
cutting his own throat.
But being scared sick looking
at it, I would say that is a
fairly extreme response as
well to the phenomenon of
childbirth.
So Hemingway is obviously
interested in people being
helpless, being unable to
protect themselves when
they're faced with the
injury of others.
It's the lack of protective
insulation.
That is a phenomenon that
Hemingway is interested in.
It's why is it that only a few
people, only people with
professional credentials, like
doctors, are well protected,
and that most of us actually
tend to be open to injury,
open to violence from others
in a very helpless way.
And it's because of that
basic configuration--
openness to the injury,
openness
to the pain of others--
that Hemingway moves
on to the last line
of this little vignette.
"It rained all through the
evacuation." On the face of
it, no connection whatsoever
with the preceding passage.
It was just about evacuation.
All of a sudden this detail
about it raining--
the only connection that I
can think of, and it's a
conjecture on my part, is that
Hemingway has so far been
talking about human phenomena.
War is very much a
man-made event.
Childbirth is a human,
man-made as well.
I mean, it's natural,
but human beings
need to bring it about.
Rain is truly a natural
phenomenon that is without
human input, without
human agency.
So what we see in this little
vignette is a movement in the
direction of naturalization.
By the time we get to the end
of the vignette, we get a
completely natural process
without human input, about
which human beings
can do nothing.
And this is the resting point.
This is the place that Hemingway
wants us to get to,
a place where we are just
passive recipients of
something that is
coming to us.
Rain is something that
just happens to us.
We know this, we've just
been through this.
Rain is something that
happens to us.
We are passive recipients,
something that happens to us.
The pain of others is natural
in exactly the same way.
And we're also passive
recipients of the pain of
others in the same way
that we are passive
recipients of rain.
There is one experiential
register that is very, very
human that is almost independent
of human agency.
It is an experience simply
defined by us as recipients,
as people who just stand
there and things being
visited upon us.
So this is, I think, very much
an affirmation of the line of
thinking already started in
"Indian Camp." It's that no
matter how well protected we
think we are, and no matter
how good we are, actually, at
what we set out to do-- and
the doctor, obviously, is a
very, very good doctor-- no
matter how good we are at what
we set out to do, there is a
limit to what that can
accomplish in the world.
And the expertise, the
professional expertise of a
doctor is always going to run
up against a natural limit.
And the pain of childbirth is,
in fact, that natural limit.
So it's very much a concession
in the direction of the
naturalness of pain and the
unavoidable intensity, and the
unavoidable violence that they
can do to other people.
So this is basically just
repeating summary
of what I just said.
Actually, I want to go
over it so that you
can think about this.
Let's move on to "The Doctor
and the Doctor's Wife." And
this one, on the face of it, it
really isn't so much about
pain, unless we think
about guilt or shame
as a kind of pain.
But it's nothing like the
extreme kind of mind-numbing,
mind-destroying pain that we see
in "Indian Camp." So it is
about the tensions between
Anglos and Native Americans.
So we're back to the macro
level about the kind of
socioeconomic tension between
two ethnic groups.
And the tension has to do with
the logs that wash ashore that
really belong to the logging
company that
Nick's father claims--
and because as far as he can
see, it's actually true-- that
they belong to nobody.
So he's trying to hire the
Native American workers, just
day laborers, to cut
up the wood.
And he gets into a row with the
Native American workers.
Dick Boulton is basically
taunting him, rubbing it in
that those logs are stolen, that
they don't belong to him,
and he's doing something
illegal.
So the professional doctor
is getting more and more
flustered as this conversation
goes on.
And it looks like something's
going to happen.
And we know that Dick
is a very big man.
He's proud of the fact that
he's such a big man.
He's not afraid of getting
into a fight.
So the stage is set,
really, for a real
inter-ethnic conflict.
And this is actually what I like
to say as the first step
towards the end of the story
which we know is actually a
happy ending.
The stage is set for the fight
to take place, the fight
doesn't take place.
What is it that stops the
fight from taking place?
What is it that makes what might
have seemed a natural
scene of violence from actually
being less than
natural, that is to
say preventable?
So preventable violence,
preventable injury, this is
what the story's about.
So this is my candidate for
the first step in that
direction towards the resolution
of violence in the
direction of peace, which is
what Hemingway is praying for
in all of these stories.
"Dick said something
in Ojibway.
Eddy laughed but Billy Tabeshaw
looked very serious.
He did not understand English
but he had sweat all the time
the row was going on.
He was fat with only
a few hairs of
mustache like a Chinaman.
He picked up the
two cant-hooks.
Dick picked up the axes
and Eddy took the saw
down from the tree.
They started off and walked up
past the cottage and out the
back gate into the woods.
Dick left the gate open.
Billy Tabeshaw went back
and fastened it."
So I think it's a really
fascinating portrait, and for
a writer who prides himself on
being completely economical,
actually it's some interesting
details.
I can't for the life of me
figure out what the point is
for comparing Billy Tabeshaw
to a Chinaman.
It's just an interesting
detail.
So it's something
to think about.
I can't offer you an explanation
why that
particular detail is in there.
The only possible reason is that
Hemingway really wants to
highlight the fact
that because he's
not an English speaker.
Therefore, all of this is
really Greek to him.
And I wouldn't put it past
Hemingway that he's
resurrecting the Greeks
in this way.
English is Greek to
Bill Tabeshaw.
So once again it looks squarely
in the direction of
inter-ethnic conflict, and
granting primacy to that
inter-ethnic conflict.
And it goes so far as to say
that here is someone who
really is completely not in the
Anglo camp, not sharing
the language at all, not even
having that common ground.
But what is really odd, and I
think that that really is the
point in emphasizing that Dick
obviously is totally fluent in
English, Billy is not
fluent at all,
can't understand anything.
But even though he doesn't
have language as to share
common ground with the Anglos,
he nonetheless knows there's
something about the chemistry
and the atmosphere of an
incipient fight that people can
pick up on even if they
don't understand the language.
So this is still Hemingway going
some distance in the
direction of naturalizing
conflict.
It is such a natural process
that language as an artificial
human invention is
not necessary.
It's not necessarily for us to
understand that something is
about to happen.
So the fact that Billy is
completely, fully in
comprehension of the situation
suggests that
conflict is very deep.
And it is so deep that we
have kind of a primitive
apprehension of its
incipience.
So what is also interesting is
that as the Native Americans,
the Indian laborers leave, they
pick up all their tools
that could be used as
potential weapons.
So they're not using those
things yet as weapons of
aggression, or self-defense,
or anything like that.
They're just still using those
as tools, they've done the
work, they're going to
take those things
away, still as tools.
But the fact that Dave has
left the gate open for me
suggests that he's also leaving
open the possibility
that those cant-hooks, the saw,
that those things that
right now are serving only as
useful tools could also be
used as weapons.
He's leaving open that
possibility.
And he would be pleased,
actually, if those tools were
to be put to a secondary
and more deadly use.
What is interesting is that
Billy-- who doesn't understand
English, but who completely
understands the situation--
is the one who goes back
and fastens the gate.
So this is a very important
detail from Hemingway, that it
is someone who really has no
personal relation, has no
ties, really, to the Anglos.
He's the one who actually
performs the important task of
closing the gate.
So he's one peacemaker coming
from a very unexpected place.
But the fact that it is Billy
who is performing that
function suggests that it's
almost a counterpoint to the
natural violence.
Just as there's a kind of a
natural tendency towards
violence, there's also
a natural tendency
to keeping the peace.
They both are firmly embedded
in us, both are
primitive in us.
And by primitive I mean
very, very powerful.
The more primitive they are, the
more deep-seeded they are,
and more likely they are
going to play out.
So being a peacemaker is
actually a very deep-seeded
desire, really, in all of us.
And it's being played
out in Billy.
And so I'd like to test another
possibility, who else
is Billy being aligned with?
If Billy is taking the first
step to stop the conflict, is
there anyone else in the
story that's completing
the work for him?
Is there anyone else in the
story that actually finishes
the task that is
begun by Billy?
And obviously, if we turn to
the ending of the story, we
see that there's a very crucial
conversation between
the doctor and the doctor's
wife, the two people who are
named in the title
of the story.
"'Dear, I don't think, I really
don't think that anyone
would really do a thing
like that.' 'No?' 'No.
I can't really believe that
anyone would do a thing of
that sort intentionally.'" And
the doctor is saying that Dick
is picking up a fight so that
he wouldn't have to pay the
medical bills, that this is all
intentional on the part of
Dick, that getting into a
fight would mean that
everything would be off between
the two of them, no
medical bills to be paid.
The doctor's wife
is saying no.
So she's saying that OK,
no, that's not likely.
"The doctor stood up and put
the shotgun in the corner
behind the dresser.
'Are you going out, dear?'
his wife said.
'I think I'll go for a walk,'
the doctor said.
'If you see Nick, dear, will you
tell him his mother wants
to see him?' his wife
said." It's an
interesting thing to say.
It's not surprising for the wife
to say, OK, if you see
our son, tell him to come in.
Except that right after she says
that, and the doctor goes
out, he slams the door.
And the wife catches her breath
as he goes out and
slams the door.
So let's think for a moment
about the two things
that the wife says.
One is that she doubts that
Dick is picking a fight so
that he wouldn't have to
pay the medical bills.
And the other thing that she
says is if you see Nick, tell
him that I want to see
him, and he should
come in to see me.
What is the effect
of saying that?
The doctor says that to Nick.
What does Nick do?
He says, I want to
go with you.
He doesn't want to go in
to see his mother.
He doesn't want to go in the
house to see his mother.
So the effect of the mother
saying I want to see Nick
actually has the effect of that
is demonstrated in the
ending of the story, is
that Nick is going
to go with his father.
And we can't think of a better
companion, a better tool for
the mother to use to stop the
doctor from getting into a
fight with his Native
American workers.
As long as Nick is there, we
know that he's never going to
get into a fight.
So the way I'm reading
the story--
and you know, obviously a
conjectural reading--
but this is the best the
doctor's wife can do as a
peacemaker, is to engineer a
scenario in which a fight is
highly unlikely to take place.
And it turns out that she is an
expert in engineering that
scenario by telling Nick to
come in to see her, she's
succeeded in exactly achieving
the outcome of the story, Nick
going off with his father to
see the black squirrels, no
violence happening.
So we can say that the three--
the two stories and the
inter-chapter--
that together all three of them
perform an all-around
meditation on violence
and pain.
One pointing in the direction of
the naturalness of violence
and pain, the other pointing
in the equal naturalness of
peace prevailing, that it
doesn't have to be.
Violence doesn't have to be.
Pain to others, pain to oneself
doesn't have to be.
It could be stopped.
It could be prevented.
So I would say this is very
typical structure in
Hemingway, is to give us
meditation on both sides of
the spectrum, testing both
possibilities, and allowing
the three to be in dialogue.
So as far as I can see, I think
that Hemingway is right,
that everything, in fact, hangs
on everything else, and
we really should see them in
relation to one another.
So we'll come back on Thursday
and we'll try out another way
of clustering the stories.